quand que tes gosses sur le terrain et a
dit annie je le sais que si je suis
blessé vous allez me sauver une pression
supplémentaire
le taux de survie si on arrivait blessés
avec des signes vitaux était de 97 pour
ça j'ai fait partie des premières corps
de ferme dans les armes de combat
on était les premières c'est certain
qu'on n'a pas fait l'unanimité
ce n'était pas une femme qui joignait
l'armée tu étais une personne qui
devenait un soldat rapidement j'ai
évacué je dirais tout l'essence féminine
que j'avais pour faire mon rôle de
soldat
si c'est comme l'insu total de se faire
dire des biens moins bons que la fille
en 1989 le tribunal canadien des droits
de la personne force l'armée canadienne
a intégré les femmes dans toutes les
sphères d'activités on ne veut pas l'on
veut pas que soit leur patente en veut
pas on essaie de pousser on essaie de
pousser tellement à bout que tu t'en
ailles toute seule claque si si la poêle
dans phase du schéma possible qu'il joue
aucune des six qui le faites le mais je
sais que c'est un de mes collègues et
étape au comptant 180 a pas que ce soit
le celle ci celle de l'afghanistan
femmes vétérans vétérans tous vétérane
la réalité des femmes qui ont servi dans
l'armée a longtemps été si inculte et
qu'on éprouve même la difficulté à les
nommer mais dans des recherches
effectuées récemment on apprend que les
femmes vétérans rapporte plus
d'incapacité plus de problèmes de santé
mentale et qu'elles sont en moyenne plus
pauvre que leurs collègues masculins
j'ai un ami que j'ai passé à avoir
j'avais un char emprunter jeter j'avais
fait faillite
p g t au sein de l'église aller chercher
de la bouffe puis-je quand l'armée est
arrivée avec toutes les beaux programmes
que tous deux coupes
ces genres de programmes le jeu réduit
les avoir dans ces années le pays
étaient disponibles dans ces années là
et personne n'a appelé personne le
dis moi j'ai passé des années de misère
pendant fonds sarah jamais dû arriver
hélène le solaire a décidé de consacrer
des études de doctorat la transition des
femmes militaires à la vie civile un
sujet qui la touche évidemment
profondément j'ai explosé mon véhicule a
explosé sur une mine
je fais des cauchemars je pense capable
de respirer
je viens en panier tout le temps mais la
journée où j'ai craqué j'ai que j'allais
l'hôpital j'étais gêné de monter parce
qu'à l'époque travel quartier on
entendit parler souvent de ce fameux
couloir de la honte
il y avait la porte pour monter aux
services de santé mentale que je me dis
bon ça y est c'est sur le monde et voilà
est faible une femme on le sait bien
c'est normal que ça nuit longue et
pénible
mouais
j'ai dix agressions sexuelles à
répétition on venait à ma chambre pour
venir menacer que si je disais quelque
chose et on allait faire plus que juste
me violer en 2015 le rapport deschamps
nous apprend que 27% des femmes ont été
victimes d'une agression sexuelle lors
de leur carrière militaire c'est à
partir de ce moment là qu anciens
combattants et l'armée vont décider de
faire de la recherche sur les femmes
on a créé cette année un bureau de la
condition féminine au ministère des
anciens combattants
on commence à peine à comprendre que les
femmes vivent plus de solitude
d'isolement et traverse une crise
identitaire plus complexe que les hommes
à leur sortie de l'armée moi j'ai été
libérée pour raisons médicales
donc j'ai pas choisi d'équité on me
montrait la porte je veux je veux pas
faire la coupure
parce que c'est ça qui donne un sens à
qui j'étais a le premier quart à les olé
côté abandonné des feuilles cinglant
singles au seigneur ce que j'ai fait ça
a pris à peu près trois minutes c'est
lever debout à m'a serré la main a
maudit bonne chose
pas de merci rien j'ai donné beaucoup
pour les forces je tenais beaucoup
d'années j'ai donné ma santé mentale
mais ça mon uniforme j'avais
l'impression que plus personne
[Musique]
salut les amis du capitaine et l'un
d'eux s'est largement développée on a
décidé aujourd'hui de montrer qu est ce
que c'est vous journée en afghanistan
pour besoin au début ça commence aussi
dans notre chambre à moins que c'est
plus - ce mais je veux encore être qui
n'a coûté que je vous confie culte est
allé parler
[Musique]
personne
j'ai un gros bagage
j'ai des super belle expérience
mais dans le quotidien maintenant
sookie